have you seen Velma on HBO Max uh yeah I
could see some kind of reimagining of
that Universe with Schwarzenegger as
Scooby-Doo whether or not you like Velma
or not it would definitely be helped by
a dog voiced by Arnold Schwarzenegger
yeah dude that's brilliant Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Scooby-Doo and he
says Hey I want to do some Scooby Snacks
because listen my friend Norwood who's
not Shaggy but he's a different guy you
know now because he's not Shaggy and he
is not doing drugs and he says so and it
doesn't even have a mystery machine car
to drive around or anything no he's just
with me you know I'm just a dog I just
talk in this voice but then when people
don't even see with smoking pot with
doing mushrooms together